joining us here from from ESPN the
columnist who I enjoy all of his work
right here
he's Bill Barnwell here on the Rich
Eisen show how are you bill Hey I'm
great thank you
man your senior writer of ESPN and the
host of the bill Barnwell show podcast
right here on the Rich Eisen show love
this idea that you had today pardon me
if I don't know if this has been an
annual thing that you've done before the
draft but to kind of counterbalance all
these mock drafts with no trades you do
a mock draft with all trades I kind of
dig that idea bill I kind of dig that
yeah we have a lot of free time on our
hands these days I was excited when I
felt confident because I know I mean the
unit so many of these are far-fetched
but I mean the concept that you had at
the first overall position it's very
wild even have a three-team parlay at
the top of a draft and I don't recall
that ever being possible but I mean it
is you're not out you're not out of the
realm I mean this isn't totally a crazy
idea I'll give you the floor how you
came up with the idea that the Dolphins
move up and get you a burrow yeah I
think you know you want to have some
semblance of logic right you want to say
if this is true then how could we make
this work so let's say you're the
Bengals you're picking first overall and
you think hey Joe bar was a great
prospect I think the Bengals are going
to take Joe bar with the first overall
pick but let's say you prefer Justin
Herbert or to attended by Louis you
could move down to three and then you
could get that guy and let the Dolphins
guess they want Joe borough we've heard
rumors say they don't want necessarily
to a tangle Milo we've heard different
things about the Dolphins maybe they go
move up to one from five and they get
your borough the Bengals move down to
three and they get the quarterback they
want from the Lions who want a defensive
player from down to five make it an
extra pick in the process the Bengals
get an extra pick in the process and the
Dolphins get the guy who might be the
best quarterback prospect in the last
thirty years who knows so you know I
think that makes sense for the Bengals
will take Joe Burrell but if they have
questions then this is an alternate that
could make some sense and then another
alternative the Dolphins you have some
fun with right here acquiring dak
Prescott from the Dallas Cowboys
where'd you where'd you cook this one up
bill okay not go over well in Dallas but
this is the logic by what I'm thinking
here yes if you're the Dallas Cowboys
you have not find that Prescott yet you
have not met his terms this price is
only going to go up over the next couple
years as more quarterback sign as the
tap goes up he's only gonna get more
expensive the last time the team started
doing this with their quarterback when I
started going through the franchise bags
with Kirk Cousins
that turned out to be a disaster for
Washington where they got a third-round
compensatory pick then a trade for Alex
Smith they attracted to Wayne Haskins
they've used so much capital to try and
replace Kirk Cousins when they could
have traded him when they decided hey
we're not going to give a sign extension
he's not worth it we're gonna go
year-to-year so if you're the Cowboys
and you think hey we're just not coming
to terms and I deal with that Prescott
then this is the time to make a trade
not next year when he's one offseason
away from great about two years from now
right when you don't have any leverage
you make the trade now and if you have a
quarterback like it to a tango buy lower
who you're in love with then hey move up
trade dak Prescott get back quarterback
now and you can build around that
quarterback and you have an expensive
roster elsewhere and for the dolphin I
mean the Dolphins are a team that look
really good
in this effort beat the Patriots they've
added a ton of talent this offseason and
Tom Brady is no longer in that division
so if he the Dolphins you might be very
interested into a tango by lower Justin
Herbert and those guys are I think are
gonna be good quarterbacks but that
Prescott is a guy where you know is more
it's pretty high right now he is a very
talented quarterback in that division
without Tom Brady might be there for the
taking so you might think okay we could
rebuild in one year and suddenly have a
quarterback might be able to win us a
vision title in 2020 which nobody was
expecting for the dolphin a few months
ago yeah let's put a pin in that AFC
East conversation for a second and just
linger a little bit with your scenarios
and try and inject a little bit of
reality into it haha although you never
know in this crazy world certainly a
week before the draft the Tewa market
what are you hearing bill about to is
market right now I think we're seeing a
lot of teams who are willing to throw
you know smoke screens out there we're
seeing teams who you know are interested
at the right price but I think it's so
difficult
because teams don't have the medical
information they would typically feel
comfortable with when it comes to these
prospectors in the same thing with Union
clowny right in free agency where you
know you're not going to give a guy you
know forty or fifty million dollars
guaranteed when you don't know if he's
totally healthy what's to I mean the pro
day looked good but we've seen a million
pro days before pro days are so
different from actual game action and if
you're at the end and you dress to a
with the third pick or the fifth pick or
the sixth pick and he's not healthy
you're gonna get fired and I think
you're seeing teams who you know the
moment of truth might be on draft day
when you have to actually sit there with
your owner and with your head coach in
that you know on a zoom call and say hey
are we willing to risk our jobs to go
after to attend my logo I think it's an
incredibly talented player but who we
just don't know how healthy here well
you saw a bill on your own I guess a
family of networks ESPN plus the great
details series that we saw the late Kobe
Bryant and can't believe I'm saying
those words Peyton Manning and now Nick
Saban lend their remarkable brain equity
to Saban essentially saying to a getting
hurt and he echoed the sentiments that
Trent Dilfer told me when Trent walked
me through how they have rebuilt to his
base is that he did too much extended
the play way too long and and the base
of his ability to throw is now going to
prevent him from having to run in extend
plays that Saban says cost him his
health in every single way shape or form
and that that won't be the case in the
pros yeah it's tough I think about guys
like Andrew Luck for example well that
was always gonna be the story with
Andrew Luck about we got to get him to
stay out of the situation's he has to
stay healthy I just don't know if you
can coach that out of a guy maybe you
can I mean hey Nick Saban there's a lot
more about football than I do and I
think it's going to be you know - it's
going to be with the best coaches on the
planet when it comes to the National
Football League but I think there's
something in made about certain
quarterbacks where they just want to
keep it sending place I just want to
make things happen and and I don't know
how successful you can really be in the
long term of Coach and I have a player's
skill set
for a year maybe for a few games here or
there if you keep reminding the guy but
it's just you know I think about Andrew
Luck and Robert Griffin
you know just guys who are so-called
Carson Wentz another example where
they're so talented and they're so tough
and they want to just make plays happen
and I think just in the heat of the
moment just your natural instincts take
over over quarterback so I think that
could be the case with to it well I know
and I know we're going crazy Bill
Barnwell here or on the Rich Eisen show
I know we're going crazy about you know
burrow and tour or it's gonna be burrow
and Herbert and to all attached at the
hip I mean you're just mentioning in
luck
rg3 Mariota obviously in Winston you can
also go on even with golf and whence you
know one of them has made a super bowl
whence still to this very moment has not
won a playoff game as a quarterback in
the NFL and I'm just wondering what you
know about how we view this like now
we're five plus years in for a lot of
these guys and seeing them on different
teams what what this means at the top of
a draft choosing a quarterback and how
risky it really really really is bill
yeah it's it's super risky but I think
the reward is so valuable I mean we're
seeing quarterbacks now get typically
top end quarterbacks looking at about
thirty five million dollars a year
somewhere in the thirty or thirty five
million dollar range depending on where
you are in your career so the
opportunity to get someone like a Carson
Wentz for four years at seven million
dollars a year it's just so valuable but
should do so much else with your
football team and if you are in the
opposite situation if you're someone
like the Seahawks Russell Wilson where
he was so cheap and they were able to
add so much talent to that roster once
he got expensive it really made it more
difficult for them to compete for a
couple years they kind of had to you
know adjust that new sort of economic
paradigm so you know I just think that
even if the hit rate is 50/50 maybe
that's fair to family what do you think
what reduce pressure I don't know I mean
it's just I mean the hit rate in terms
at the top of the draft right I mean you
want to talk mahomes where he was taken
Watson where he was taken Lamar Jackson
where he was taken Jimmy G where he was
taken I mean at the top of the draft a
top-five drafted quarterback I mean
again I'm just going off the top of my
dome here about somebody it was taking
top-five transformative and
we got the team's got what they needed
which was using their first iteration of
their contract where they're not
breaking the bank to the tune of a large
percentage of the cap and winning right
there to spread it around to the rest of
the team like that's the idea that's
what the Seattle Seahawks obviously did
with Russell Wilson what the Chiefs have
been able to pull off with mahomes and
might be able to do again I that's why
I'm saying like maybe you sit back and
wait and you find your guy later in the
draft in the same way that you talk
about running backs and wide receivers
maybe we could start thinking about
quarterbacks that way I'm honestly just
like your your article just spitballing
here
look at that draft from a couple years
ago where you know Sam Donald came off
the board there we still don't know
what's happening with same dharna
because obviously you know that hadn't
been able to surround him with enough
talent Lamar Jackson is what 32 I think
he was 31 or 32 he was the last pick of
the draft yeah ice pick in Dallas turned
out okay for the Ravens you know he's
pretty sure you know the end of the day
I think when you have these quarterbacks
was talented as they are so much of what
we're gonna see is about what you put
around them the talent you put around
them the players you put around them
look at Josh Allen a guy who we all kind
of thought okay he's a prospect coming
out of school major question marks you
know Josh I look pretty good last year
and because the dole spent so much in
terms of draft capital in terms of free
agency starting him for solid offensive
line stranding him with the receivers he
needed a running game that was effective
and put Josh out in a situation where he
didn't have to be that guy like a luck
or a Griffin or Wentz where he had to
put the team on his back and make plays
you have to be kind of selective and not
turn the ball over and they had a long
winning streak because Josh Allen will
be able to play that brand of football
so I think so much of this comes back to
not just the talents of the player but
also the coaching staff yeah I think and
to put a button on this this whole part
of our conversation bill you touched
upon at the beginning here about an
interesting concept that I don't think
we've seen which is the rest of the AFC
East seeing a window of opportunity to
push a button now and win now and take
advantage of the now with Brady out of
the division we you're you're you know
again you're you're thrown out all these
scenarios that
dolphins might actually go and hit the
win it now button with either a trade or
what they're doing in the draft and then
the bills going and getting Stefon Diggs
and what they're doing do you think that
this is the bills division to lose right
now in 2020 I do yeah I mean honestly I
thought they outplayed the Patriots in
those two games last year now granted
they lost both games but they both came
down to a few points here and there I
think a blocked punt in the first game
and then that last drive from Josh Allen
in the second game where I put the bills
are the better team of the two in those
two games and then the Patriots lose Tom
Brady they lost a bunch of players from
that defense that really carried them
last season they're a team that's in
transition we don't know what Jerry said
he's going to be maybe he's going to be
great you don't want to count Bill
Belichick out but at the end of the day
if you're the bills and we've been
waiting 20 years for your chance for the
Dolphins and even waiting 20 years for
your Chancery or the Jets in the same
boat you have to feel like this is your
opportunity and you have to feel like
it's the right situation you know
approaches you know what I spend money
for the sake of spending money but I
think on big straight is perfect where
it's hey we're gonna take a risk but we
built this strong culture this is a
superstar player we don't have access to
elsewhere let's see if we can kind of
take that leap and be the dominant team
in this division so I do think the bills
are in the driver's seat but if the
defense lifts if Josh Allen doesn't play
well next year which I mean we've seen a
lot of guys look at him you're to
struggle in year three Metra basically
comes to mind as a recent example you
know I think the Dolphins could be in
position to possibly compete for
Division title and I think that has to
this be in your mind if you're one of
these three other teams in the AFC ESPN
senior writer bill Barnwell here on the
Rich Eisen show one of the things I
really like about your work is you can
really go deep and connect dots and and
use salary caps and take what trades in
the past have netted in terms of draft
choices and put it all together so
that's my backdrop for asking you what
are the Texans doing what is Bill
O'Brien
doing from the acquisition of David
Johnson and sending away DeAndre Hopkins
in the acquisition of Brandon cooks put
this all together for me I have enough
time
and to figure out the magic and mystery
of what Brian is doing what I would say
I think about you know Bill O'Brien
worked underneath Bill Belichick I think
about what Bill Belichick would do in
situations in the past he's traded the
way those wide receivers when he felt
like they were kind of past their their
point of being useful to the team Terry
Glenn comes tonight at the beginning of
the Patriots dynasty Randy Moss recently
they've traded the way veterans from
those Patriots teams for years it's just
like Tom Brady leave so you think or
anyone can go but I just think we're
seeing a guy who you know doesn't think
about the draft the same way other teams
think about the draft kind of sees those
picks is more replaceable perhaps and
they should be so you know going out and
getting a Duke Johnson that's a totally
fine players what a solid player giving
up a program take to do so and he is
probably gonna get cut if the Browns
didn't get a trade offer doesn't make a
lot of sense
you know the let me concentrate hey
you're getting a superstar left tackle
in the prime of his career that's
totally fine understand giving up a lot
of draft capital to make that happen but
you have to sign him to a contract when
you do it because otherwise he's gonna
have you over apparently can do whatever
he wants in terms of leverage because he
knows you're not gonna let me go after
you traded two first-round picks to make
this deal happen so I think we're just
seeing a guy who doesn't think about
things from the value perspective when
it comes to making these trades and just
thinks about players which is part of
the job but that's the coaching side of
the job from the GM side of the job you
have to understand what the pixel was
what the contract situation is how the
Catholics and I think we're seeing Bill
O'Brien really struggle with that side
of things when it comes to the trace
he's making well I mean the letter
grades you've given him for the Hopkins
trade and then the cooks trade date they
get progressively worse to the point
where we're seeing letters of the
alphabet we usually don't see associated
with good grades so again again and so
because what you're paying cooks right
you would have paid close to what
Hopkins wanted and you keep a guy there
that the team and the city already wants
to stay and can go after Andre Johnson's
team records if he keeps going there
right and and then I guess you say I
took Carlos Hyde from the Chiefs and I'm
he's a thousand yard rusher
and my system can do that for David
Johnson I it's really just I'm
scratching my head right now bill you're
not seeing it but I'll just describe you
I'm literally scratching my head that
said though we were wondering what the
hell's he doin trading away clowny like
that and then doing what he did with
Tunsil I had a a several touchdown lead
on the road against the eventual Super
Bowl champs we all know what happened
but you know that's why I'm trying to
say like is there a possibility he does
have a method here and his madness will
actually work I mean you know these are
talented players Brandon cooks was a
good football player Larry consoles an
excellent left tackle I don't think the
issue here is necessarily you know the
players in a vacuum but it's just you
know you have to win us the rules make
this work right look at the Rams the
Rams traded a ton of their draft picks
away those were on a core nine or 10
guys and they made it to the Super Bowl
they came within a touchdown of winning
that Super Bowl in me that one tip pass
away from winning the Super Bowl and if
they win all the stuff we've seen this
offseason about how they fail how the
Gurley contract the Kochs contract
hasn't worked doesn't matter because
they have a Super Bowl in their building
and that's all that you care about at
the end of the day so that's a really
high bar and granted
like you say they were up 20 points I
think on the Chiefs in the divisional
round they were also trailing to the
bills in the wild-card round this is a
team that I think you look at the
numbers for the Texans you would think
are even before these trades they were
likely to decline next year there was
some things about their performance
especially in close games that makes you
think they're gonna struggle in 2020 and
if that happens the guy who comes to
might remain is Chip Kelly right a guy
who you know had his team in the
playoffs look like he really had you
know kind of the sort of the next modern
great coach he can get that GM power
make some moves we kind of have
questions about a bunch of running backs
you know a trades for Sam Bradford
science Byron Axl to a huge contract
when it doesn't work out the Eagle said
hey you're not a good GM your coach and
we fire them from both jobs and they're
being downhill from there for Chip Kelly
so I don't want Bill O'Brien to get
fired I think he's done a good enough
job as a coach to deserve plenty of time
as the coach there in Houston but if
this does kind of fail you have to
figure it's going to fail pretty
ocularly and it's getting quite
disappointing and it could lead to some
dramatic changes to the Texans now we
obviously have to see but I think you
know it's going to be so much on deshaun
Watson and in those new receivers to gel
together in a very difficult and very
uncommon off season it could be a
situation where it does take them some
time to jail them at that point
the Texans could already be you know
kind of trying to catch up before I let
you go bill barn well this conversation
was all born out of your 32 picks 32
trades
article on espn.com today where you're
just throwing a bunch of trades out
there that may or may not happen most
likely not and the conversation in the
NFL world because of a report coming out
of New York City that Odell might be on
the move again to Minnesota for a two
and a five I'm wondering what you think
of if you want to grade that possible
deal between the Browns and the Vikings
if this does in fact happen in this
manner bill it'd be interesting you know
I would kind of be in the middle for
both and I think in the c+ range for
both of them because I can see the
Vikings adding him but you know it's
just treated the bondages you're in a
draft that has a ton of wide receiver
talent well I'm gonna go out and get
Odell at this point he's making 14
million dollars a year he want to be a
team that runs the football I can't
imagine Odell is going to be thrilled
with that offense and then from the
brown side you just traded for it all
back in and granted you've changed your
you know your GM you changed your your
head codes you might have some different
feelings here but this is a brown
student needs to figure out what they
had with Baker Mayfield you can't wait
any longer you have to see what you have
in year three and Jarvis Landry had hip
surgery he's already out for pretty much
the entirety of the office there's a
question mark for week one so even given
that this was a great track for wide
receivers I just don't see why you would
so low on Odell Beckham and possibly
head into week one of a must not a
must-win vide but he must improve season
will Baker Mayfield with to Ricky white
receivers or you know a couple backup
the wide receiver just doesn't thing
that can make sense for them at the time
but hey you know the Giants said we
didn't sign or go back in to trade him
and then anything is possible
bill thanks for the time really
appreciate everybody check out Bill's
podcast and of course all of his great
work on ESPN and ESPN com appreciate the
time bill
appreciate it it's not honor mr. anytime
oh please right back at you bill its
bill Barnwell here on the show hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here